moi je crois qu'on ne peut pas faire de
la politique n'importe comment et avec
n'importe quoi mais au fond en marche
c'est quoi eux savent de quoi je ne vais
pas encore tout à fait saisi je n'en
prenais pas pris la ligne politique non
mais j'ai un nom mais je consomme je
constate me direz droite ni de me nommer
certains se plaignent surtout que ce que
ce que ce soit surtout une caisse de
résonance pour un seul homme veut et je
n'ai pas l'impression qu'avec cela est
de cette façon cela s'inscrira dans la
durée
ouais dès lors si ça veut s'inscrire
dans la durée il faudra plus que
l'attrait qui est considérable je
concède d'instinct seul homme fût-il
président de la république